even the casting choices and across the
spiderverse contain Easter eggs among
the varied voice casts are also two
members of The Lonely Island a sketch
Troop that gained notoriety on Saturday
Night Live yormo takoni who previously
voiced several minor characters and into
the spider-verse appears early on as a
variant of the vulture inspired by
Leonardo da Vinci alongside zirconi Andy
Samberg also makes an appearance in the
film's Ben Reilly AKA Scarlet Spider
during his first appearance in the film
some bugs Riley is seen in the wave of
York contemplating his tragic backstory
before later joining O'Hara and hunting
down Morales on Earth 1610. samberg's
appearance in particular may be an
Easter egg to his work on Saturday Night
Live one of those times has joined the
monologue of Emma Stone in 2011 where he
unsuccessfully tried to recreate the
2002 film's iconic makeout scene with
her in front of her then boyfriend and
co-star Andrew Garfield he's
record unemployment and we Outsource
Spider-Man to England